salut aujourd'hui on reçoit douli douli
c'est une humoriste elle est très très
drôle elle a une carrière avec un
parcours atypique parce qu'elle a
commencé en étant dame pipi dans les
toilettes d'une boîte de nuit mais sa
spécificité c'est qu'elle a atteintre de
la maladie de Charco marit tous et c'est
une maladie qui fait extrêmement mal et
comment on résiste à la douleur quand on
veut pas prendre de médicament parce que
on est une ancienne héroïnomane et ben
juste on a le rire pour ça et elle a la
générosité de venir nous parler de ça
aujourd'hui
dou toi tu es la seule personne que je
connaisse qui commence ses spectacles en
expliquant qu'elle pas ouais je suis
obligé non mais je suis vraiment obligé
chérie parce que vraiment pour le coup
on a fait des tests assez récemment
parce que tout le monde m'a dit mais non
mais c'est bon arrête tout le monde
parce qu'en plus quand tu me connais tu
tu tu te dis pas elle fait
vraiment torcher ouais on sait que tu
l'ai je sens qu'il y a eu un doute dans
ton
regard non mais quand quand quand on te
connaît que tu vas sur scène moi la
blague elle me fait toujours rire et je
me dis toujours c'est sûr qu'il y en a
dans le public que tu viens de les
unlock en fait mais c'est sûr parce que
c'est sûr que c'est sûr c'est pour ça
que j'essaie d'expliquer et c'est vrai
que là on a eu un test assez probant
avec Jason broker et far et tout ça on
avait essayé vraiment là avec les mêmes
vannes si je le dis pas ça fonctionne
pas mais au-delà de ça c'est que dire à
des gens je suis pas bourré en soi c'est
pas du tout une blague donc sachant que
ça n'est pas une blague et que les gens
rient ça veut dire qu'ils ontst ils
étaient en train de se dire mais
chir elle ou quoi tu vois parce que
Madame sfati par exemple là où je joue
le plus souvent euh tu as des serveuses
qui sont un peu comme des ninjas et elle
passe entre les gens comme ça et tu les
entends pas et ell me disent douli à
chaque fois tu Mones ch parce que
quelque fois je tarde un peu à le dire
tu vois et toute cette minute est très
pesante pour tout le monde c'est dire
non il y a une vraie tension quoi non
c'est un questionnement c'est pas qu' se
disent que tu l'es et qui se questionn
je pense qu'en plus ils essayent
d'analyser à quoi je suis déchiré tu
vois je
elle peut tout prendre tu en as pas
marre de justifier tout le temps
là-dessus non mais j'aimerais bien
parfois juste monter sur scène tu vois
avec tu penses à une idée tu
disigé fasse un petit Laus quand même
mais vraiment c'est important parce que
je te jure mais ça c'est sur scène dans
la vraie vie j'imagine que tu commences
pas tes conversations par je m'aelle
jeis pas bouré je pense que énormément
de cas les gens pensent que je suis
déchiré mais je te dis récemment il y a
un taxi qui m'a
dit je lui dit horors les 3 s'il vous
plaît à 5h du Matth il m'a dit au bout
de 5 minutes si ça va pas vous prévz je
m'arrête ah ouais il était 5h du match
j'avais ma valise et tout le gars il a
cru que j'allais en after avec
douli ça fait quoi d'avoir la voix la
plus douce du show du show business
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
luxe non c'est sympa bah j'aurais pas
aimé avoir la voix aigue tu me diras si
tu redemandes de choisir à la naissance
avec une voix aigue je prense celleel
quand même est-ce que je peux du coup
tu'imaginer à 6 ans avec cette voix ou
ou ouais c'est ça que ah oui oui j'avais
la voix j'avais la voix déjà mais on
prenait pour un mec quand j'étais petite
est-ce que est-ce que tu ASAS tu avais
les cordes vocales comme ça descendu et
grave dès le départ j'avais déjà
peut-être pas aussi grave mais elle
était cassée ouais ok et qu ma mère me
raser la tête tu vois du coup tout le
monde m'a
je te raser la tête ta ouais elle m'a
rasé la tête mais parce que tu as des
pou pour le plisirou exactement oui oui
et pour pas se faire chier quoi ah Bahou
la technique est l'ancienne c'est moins
cher que le shampoing allez hop là bah
ouais du coup avec ses doigts et la tête
rasé tu vois ça petit soldat quoi
incroyable j'ai l'impression d'entendre
un épisode de malcol en vrai tu vois une
vraie vie tu avais même enregistré cet
été ta voix sur le GPS à ah ouais mais
c'est ton idée quelle bonne idée il a eu
c'est vraiment fou la quantité de gens
parce que en plus je voulais pas trop
saouler non plus peutêtre qu'il y en a
ils aiment pas tu vois donc du coup mais
la quantité de gens qui se sont film
même en
piéton en piéton au Japon enfin tu sais
genre des trucs improbables et je
voulais faire des petits montages tu
sais peut-être avec des des clips de de
rappeurs dans leur
bagnole
sera génial ça ça pour être
marrant est-ce que ça t'a porté
préjudice quand même ta voix est-ce que
tu as vra tu as vraiment des moments où
tu te rends compes que tu as pas eu un
je sais pas moi un crédit d'appart un
machin et tout juste à cause de la voix
ou c'est pas allé à ce stade là non mais
je pense que si je pense qu'il y a des
fois des taxis ont pas voulu me prendre
ou tu sais où tu es dans le speed en
plus tu vois tu étais vraiment très très
en retard et là tu peux pas dire je suis
pas bourré de toute façon c'est ce que
les gens qui sont bourrés c'est
exactement ça le le le comble qui a chez
et toi c'est que tout le monde pense que
tu es bourré alors que non mais par
contre si tu dis que tu es handicapé
personne ne te croit personne me croit
c'est ça qui est ouf est-ce que est-ce
que tu peux nous parler en 2 secondes de
la maladie dont tu souffres pour les
personnes oui c'est une maladie bon
c'est une maladie dégénérissante donc
fatalement il y a pas vraiment d'espoir
mais mais elle se traduit sous
différentes formes selon les gens moi
c'est ça abîe les tendons quoi enfin
c'est plus ou moins pour tout le monde
pareil donc du coup tu as des tendons
qui ser rétracte et moi essentiellement
c'est la position debout qui me qui me
fait mal quoi ça fatigue énormément
enfin tu as plein de trucs quoi il y a
plein de gens qui ont des des des
versions différentes quoi de ça en tout
cas ça se voit pas enfin pas trop si on
a les pieds on a les pieds qu'on
a parce que ça cambre les piedsnmment
ouis mais oui du coup bah quand tu sors
la car que ça se voit pas ouais c'est C
technique ouais c'est ça ah bah quand
quand Quand tu es dans le bus et que si
tu en peux plus et qu'il faut s'asseoir
en disant je suis handicapé je mettre là
c'est très gênant c'est très gênant les
rares fois où je l'ai fait bah c'était
compliqué et maintenant j'attends d'être
avec des copains pour le faire mais
c'est dommage quoiou ou quand j'en peux
vraiment plus ouais oui parce que là ça
devient de la survie après mais même
dans les aéroport tu demandes il faut
demander aux agents de SCU de t'amener
carrément parce que le me pour
légitimiser le truc oui parce que le mec
il te dit ouais mais traverser ces 500
personnes qui vont vous détester et donc
tu dis non mais non non viens avec moi
parce que en plus com on fait un pe ces
métiers tu vois je me dis toujours à
quel part ils vont se dire ça y est nana
fait deux vidéos elle passe devant tout
B ça c'est vrai mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec ta maladie quoi mais ouais tu vois
c'est un peu chiant quoi qu' se soit
associé à ça aussi vrai c'est encore
plus chiant qu quand est-ce que tu as tu
as capté que tu avais un souci ah très
très rapidement non mais c'est une
maladie qui a été diagnosti très tôtou
très tard très tard mais je savais que
j'étais chelou je sais quoi tu sais tu
as pas de réflexe avec cette maladie
donc tuas les médecins il me tapaient
dans dans les genoux et tout ça il y a
rien il sa'est jamais rien passer titin
mais laissez-moi tranquille je n'ai pas
de réflexe tu as plein de trucs comme ça
tu peux pas écrire moi je pouvais pas
écrire normalement tu vois pouvais pas
écrire comme ça ok donc j'écrivais comme
ça euh il y a plein de trucs comme ça et
après tout est expliqué oui parce que tu
as une maladie qui explique tout ce que
tu trouvais chelou dans les petits
détails du cotidien qui ou marrant ça
c'est assez marrant ça t'a ça t'a
soulagé de savoir ou pas parce que
mosant de voir que tous les sites vois
sur le site du Téléton c'est ça mais bon
écoute comme si toujours enfin tu sais
c'est pas en j'essaie de faire oublier
aux gens et quand tu essayes de faire
oublier aux gens tu l'oublies aussi
ouais euh si tout le monde est au
courant ou si tout le monde sait que Ten
chies du matin au soir ils vont tous te
faire ma peau ouais ça c'est c'est pas
possible parce qu'en fait même les jours
où tu veux oublier que tu as mal et ben
les gens te le rappellent en fait ça va
aujourd'hui tu es sûr non tuas une
petite tu devrais un peu tu joues trop
en ce moment calme un peu calme un peu
noublie pas que tu es handicapé tu vois
c'est mieux de fermer sa gueule en fait
ouais je comprends mais juste pour
terminer avec ce sujet là est-ce que ça
t'a fait du bien avec tes grands
guillemets de mettre une étiquette qui
expliquait le reste ou pasis je pense
que c'est pas mal d'avoir ça parce que
après tu peux mieux tourner la page et
avancer quoi oui non mais surtout je dis
ça pour les gens qui ont plein parce
qu'il y a 80 % handicapés qui sont
invisibles des handicap oui c'est ça et
pas c'est pas les handicapés qui sont
invisibles handicap il peut-être des
handicapé invisible aussi mais du coup
non tu sais il y en a plein ils ont des
ils ont des maladies ils ont pas accès à
la carte handicapé parce que leur
maladie n'est pas référencée quoi entre
guillemets tu vois donc c'est horrible
parce que tuen chie et tu peux même pas
tu sais les gens il disent oui oui c'est
bon a fase mal oui c'est ça ça fait un
peu fausse maladie que tu t'inventes
dans ta tête tu vois ouais euh donc oui
c'est toujours bien d'avoir un un vrai
truc quoi un vrai nom à dire quand les
gens ça t'est déjà arrivé des gens qui
te croient pas non parce que j'essaie de
m' tourner de personnes sympathiques
mais mais euh mais non oui dans la vie
dans les bus et tout oui c'est une
catastrophe dans les busouais la la
France elle a vraiment la réputation
d'être un très mauvais pays concernant
le handicap bah c'est mauvais je pense
qu'il y a d'autres mauvais mais eux sont
très mauais on est très mauvais tu as
jamais une chaise ou un ban et même un
banc sur ils ont dégagé tous les bans
moi j'aimerais bien des bans de temps en
temps ou juste pour faire une pause comm
place ou bien sûr mais il y a plein de
plein de trucs qu'on a pas nous et qu'il
y a dans d'autres pays tu vois même les
salles de spectacle excuse-moi elles
sont pas hyper bien équipé pour les
handicapés quoi ça a l'air d'être très
compliqué la France au niveau du
handicap et et au niveau de la de
comprendre ce qu'une personne peut vivre
tu vois de ce que to pe ou justement
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire des
blagues dessus parce que je pense que
c'est pas en disant oui vous êtes tous
des connards pas laisser la place en
fait quand tu accuses les gens parfois
c'est même pas de leur faute tu vois on
a tous eu des pensées en se disant non
mais attends l'autre pourquoi elle me
passe devant euh on peut pas juger ça
par contre c'est cool de faire des
blagues dessus parce que du coup les
gens qui ont ce truc ils rient là-dessus
ils disent ah moi aussi c'est vrai que
j'ai déconné la fois où je fais ça tu
vois ouais c'est pas bête et puis avec
les blagues tu peux donner ton vécu et
quand tu donnes ton vécu par une blague
on l'AC accepte beaucoup plus on le on
s'imprène de ça tu vois c'est ça j'ai
j'avais vécu sur le handicap ça me
revient maintenant je devais passer 24
heures aveugle juste pour vivre un peu
ce que c'était et j'étais ok je vais le
vivre mais je j'ai déjà compris ce qu'il
vivent tu vois et je l'ai fait à la fin
de la journal je me su j'ai rien compris
à ce qu'il vivent le premier truc tu
sais qui a été fou pour moi c'est de me
balader dans la rue d'arriver au resto
de replier la canne et d'avoir les mains
pleines de merde je me suis jamais si je
l'avais pas vécu j'aurais capté à ça B
avec les fauteuils ils ont ça aussi ah
ouais c'est ouf tu vois tous ces trucs
où tu dis ouais ouais on a nous tous
l'impression nous tous valide qu'on a
compris par contre ce qui était l'
handicap parce que je pense qu'il y a
aucune personne qui se qui qui qui pense
s'en du handicap tu vois
individuellement on est tous certain
d'être très informé tu vois c'est très
dur de se mettre à la place des gens je
te dis regarde moi qui me suis pété une
côte toute ma vie on m'a dit me fais
barriir parce que j'ai une côte cassée
là j'ai compris que tu étais une grosse
merde en fait quand tu avais une côte
cassée tu fais rien donc en fait tu te
mets toujours un peu à la place des gens
mais maisas on a tous ce truc de dire
oui ça va c'est bon c'est bon je peux
faire un effort quoi oui alors qu'en
vrai même parfois tu te coupes avec une
miette de pain et tuen chies pendant une
semaine alors es la seule personne quand
même avec une miette de pain tu coupes
pas avec des miettes de pain attends
jeis me retourner vers les cadreurs vous
vous coupez avec des MI de pain les gars
vousêtes jamais coupé avec des miettes
de pain deny mange du pain de alors non
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais avec ton
mais qui a du pain qui coupe tu m'aurais
dit avec une feuille de papier je dis
pas mais avec une miette de pain c'est
très spécifique non mais si des fois tu
coupes le pain comme ça tuas tu as le
truc non non mais toi oui ben tu vois on
va se mettre à ta place alors
raconte c'est B ça que je peux pas
toujours faire dans les spectacles vous
aussi ça vous arrive pas applaudissement
et là tu as une personne non dou non non
je sais que je débrive toujours avec des
amis en amont ouais bah ouais tu il y a
qu'un mois que ça arrive d'accord toi
alors tu parles de M de pain c'est
aucune transition avec la suite mais tu
prenais de
l'héros rien à voir hein bah si tu peux
trouver des petite biett de pain de
l'éros franchement dans le contexte on
est bien sur un un délire cludo quel
niveau tu sais comment j'ai fait mon
lien c'est parce que tu disais que tu
avais mal en te coupant avec des bettes
de pain et ça m'a fait penser au fait
que tu prenais pas d'antidouleur malgré
toutes les douleurs que tu su je me
demandais si c'est cétait parce que tu
étais une ancienne héroïomane alors ça
en fait partie oui ça fait partie des
raisons bah parce que tous les
antidouleurs ont des opiacés dedans
enfin les vrais quoi les trucs qui font
quelque chose quoi donc mais c'est un
choix parce que c'est pas ça qui moi on
m'a mis sous an douleur pendant 5 ans
bien après que j'ai arrêté les ruines ça
m'a jamais fait pllonger dans les ruines
mais c'est juste que pour moi pour mon
corps et mon cerveau l'effet est le même
ouais et et le manque est le même
surtout c'est très fort comme traitement
parce que en plus fatalement les opacés
bah on va pas tuis c'est agréable alors
il y a une partie de la population qui
supporte pas ça qui ça fait gerber et
tout et qui ont plus le contrôle de rien
donc il déteste ça mais sinon
globalement les gens aiment
l'opium c'est pas un
secret globalement les gens a mais
regarde il y a pas si longtemps que ça
c'était vendu en pharmacie genre le
meilleur MOC de la planète donc oui on
est d'accord c'est génial mais si tu le
prends et que tu es pas tu as pas été
addicte à à des produits avant et que tu
connais pas le mécanisme des drogues toi
dans ta tête tu dis oh là là c'est
génial ma journée elle était beaucoup
plus cool avec de l'opium et tu reprends
le lendemain bah oui sauf que tu sais
pas que ce truc là va te faire
exactement le même effet que le mec qui
qui se pique sur la colline du crack on
on on juge beaucoup du coup les junky et
on fait pas gaffe qu'on a la même
puissance mais avec prescription et
légalité quoi ch c'est la même chose
ouais c'est ouf sauf qu'il y en a un qui
est pas remboursé par la SCU quoi ouais
c'est dégueulasse non dis pas lequel on
garde du
suspense du coup comment tu gères tes
douleurs toi
euh je gre pas vraiment j'ai pas de
de non je pense que c'est les gens qui
me font oublier ok euh si tu restes
focus sur toi je pense qu'il faut pas
trop rester faut pas s'intéresser à soi
en fait si faut aller faire des massages
et des trucs chose que je fais pas mais
ça c'est cool t'occuper de toi ouais
mais pas mais pas pas focus VO non non
faut rigoler avec des gens franchement
rigoler faire du sport Faire du sport
c'est pas mal parce que pour pour pour
bien préciser on est d'accord que tu as
une douleur constante oui c'est constant
non non mais c'est là on rigole et tout
mais c'est pas rien quand même quoi tu
vois tu vois j'en ch pour me tenir
droite ouais sinon je ser ouais ah non
mais c'est ouf donc le sport ça te
soulage le rire aussi j'imagine tu te
Mar moi je te depuis que je te connais
je t'ai toujours connu de bonne humeur
jamais
connu devant les gens oui c'est c'est
mie mais oui ça sert à rien tu sais quoi
moi j'ai des potes à chaque fois que je
leur dis ça pas et tu me dis et
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça ouis et tu
dis c'est vrai une fois qu'on a dit ça
bah s'est rien passé de plus tuas pas
trouvé de solution entre temp c'est vrai
que non c'est sympa de se plaindre
parfois tu te plins pendant 10 minutes
tu dis j'en ai Maren parce que tu tu te
Soulages juste tu as quelqu'un qui a
entenduou mais en plus c'est très chiant
d'entendre quelqu'un se plaindre quoi
c'est surtout moi rassure sur ma
vie non c'est chiant d'entendre
quelqu'un se plaindre et en plus général
tu as pas grand chose à lui dire à part
je comprends donc on peut rire de tout
tout le temps oui non non attends quand
tu es énervé ou tu es très triste il a
un mec il arrive il fait tu sais tu as
vraiment envie de le il y a que toi qui
connais des gens qui font e faut virer
ces gensl de ta vie non tu sais tu sais
il y a des gens qui essayent toujours de
de faire la vanne de trop quand il voit
que tu es pas bien c'est bon coupe
est-ce que en parlant de vanne déplacé
est-ce que ça t'es déjà arrivé de
trouver pour ton spectacle des vannes
sur ton passé desinoman ou sur ta
maladie qui te font mourir de rire mais
alors pas du tout le public qui te
suivent pas du tout ouou oui oui oui ah
oui oui puis moi puis moi je continue
c'estàd non là ça devient drôle non mais
c'està dire qu'il y a vraiment des Vanes
que j'ai dû garder longtemps et à chaque
fois je sortais de scène on me disait tu
es sûr de toi vraiment et parce que j'y
croyais vraiment parce que en fait mais
on était trois sur la planète que ça
faisait rire quoi ouais ouais parce que
je pense qu'en plus il y a un cont il
fallait avoir vécu ce que tu raconté
pour vraiment
oui je pense qu'il y a un contexte et il
y a un contexte aussi cérébral tu vois
si tu veux quand tu es connecté à des
gens sur une connerie et que cette
connerie fait écho à une autre connerie
tu vois c'est un pingpong que les autres
ont pas forcément dans ou mais sinon
tout le monde fera des spectacles parce
que les trucs qui te font marrer entre
potes dans cette connexion là c'est très
private ouais ouais bah il y a des
Privat que j'ai gardé longtemps mais bon
ben elles ont elles ont saué à un moment
donné je me suis fait plaisir pendant un
mois ça c'était pas moiéit pour moi il y
a il y a il y a un truc incroyable dans
ton histoire que je connaissais pas
c'est la rencontre que tu as faite en
Israël avec un médecin un peu à part tu
peux nous le raconter il est bah il est
pas à part en fait c'est un vrai médecin
c'est pas un gourou non non mais à part
dans le sens cette rencontre là elle est
très fortte il fait ouais il fait des il
aide les les junky à tous les opiacés ok
à s' sortir
ouais par une technique que j'arrive
jamais à expliquer mais en
fait il fait
ta famille non mais que les les
récepteurs de ton cerveau tu es les
récepteurs de de de des opioïdes quoi
restent un peu ouvert quand tu as été
consommateur pendant longtemps et du
coup lui referme ça donc en fait tu n'es
plus en demande ton corps n'est plus en
demande de ça après libre àtoi de
replonger he enfin tu vois c'est pas
miraculeux en soi mais ça t'enlève le M
mais si tu as envie d'arrêter ça va
t'aider à arrêter puisque ça va t'aider
sur ton manque ou ouais ouais mais je
crois qu'il fait vraiment que les
opiaceris parce qu'il y a des gens qui
étaient addictes à à d'autres drogues
qui m'ont demandé je crois que lui fait
vraiment que les opiacer ouis parce que
parce que c'est spécifique dans le
cerveau pour le coup pour connaître un
peu ça les opiaacés c'est un peu comme
pour la nicotine la première fois que tu
en prends ça te crée des récepteurs qui
vont s'allumer en alerte rouge et qui
vont jamais
disparaître
voilà et d'ailleurs ils vont atteindre
un point où à un moment donné pendant
que tu es en train de consommer ils sont
déjà en train de se rallumer enfin c'est
c'est la la grosse dépendance tu vois
effectivement lui combien de temps il a
réussi à à faire ça 24 heur c'est fou
c'est même pas je crois que c'est
quelques heures mais mais tu restes une
semaine et mais ça dure le d'enlever le
truc le manque la sensation de manque
c'est même pas 24 heur quoi ça a dû êre
incroyable toi tu étais déjà dans la
démarche du coup de vouloir arrêter à
ceououi non moi j'allais pas bien du
tout c'est ma grand-mère et tout ça qui
m'ont qui qui qui m'ont aidé à aller le
voir mais
oui c'est c'est ça moi ça été plus long
parce que je prenais en plus des
cachetons des trucs donc mais c'est
vraiment incroyable et tu as tatoué son
nom à se mcin dans ton dos c'est ouf
ouais il le sait ouais
ouais ouais c'est très très je trouve
c'est très fort quoi comme geste tu voou
ou c'est c'est une très belle rencontre
com comment on fait pour parler de la de
la drogue
euh en spectacle h sans être ni dans la
propagande ni moralisatrice ah ça
tuétait très compliqué très compliqué
mais justement c'est un peu tuas dit les
deux les deux trucs quoi ouis c'est les
deux pièges tu dois naviguer entre ces
deuxl ouais bah il y a une frontière
assez me quoi je reste pas milans dessus
non plus parce que il y a des publics
bien évidemment qui vont être hyper
réceptifs à ça et et parce qu'ils ont
connu parce que ça mais ceux qui
connaissent pas du tout tu peux pas
faire un lus de 20 minutes sur la drogue
quoi qui ferait énormément rire soit les
drogués soit les anciens drogués mais
parce que il y a des expressions et tout
ça mais toutes ces expressions je ne
peux pas les utiliser c'est niche ouais
ça fait un tout petit public a pas de
tune parce qu'il se drogue de toute
manière donc pas très intéressant la
bonne cible d dit on sort de
là mais mais ce qui est drôle c'est
justement d'arriver à faire rire des tu
vois des mecs de de 80 piges et tout ça
m'est arrivéin d'avoir de trois mecs au
premier rang comme ça ou des nanas et
ilar sur des blagues de droguer et mais
de droguer de repenti quoi ouais c'est
ça ouais parce que moi je trouve que
c'est fort c'est pas la je là dans son
dans ton show déjà j'ai pas l'impression
que tu parles de drog mais de dou en
fait dans machin et et ça fait pas
propagande et en même temps tu donnes
pas la morale mais le fait que tu sois
repenti entre guillemets ça donne déjà
la thématique quoou c'est ça de toute
façon ça sert à rien de dire à quelqu'un
ne te drogue pas c'est pas parce que tu
vas lui dire ne te drogue pas qu' va pas
se
droger la négative sur n'importe quelle
phrase ne nous a jamais interdit de
faire quoi que ce soit et pu alors tu
sais quoi le cerveau ne comprend pas la
négation donc limite il entend
l'inversement ben oui mais plus tu vas
me dire fais pas ça plus je vais le
faire enfin c'est terrible mais c'est
comme ça on est on est fait comme ça il
y a il y a d'autres sujets pour lesquels
c'est dur d'écrire pour ton spectacle
bah le handicap CIT pas facile parce
Queau début euh tu sais j'ai écris des
Vanes sur les handicapés mais il fallait
déjà que j'accepte que je l'étais
moi-même ouais donc après tu te dis et
et en fait c'est le genre de Van il faut
les assumer vraiment pour qu'ell Prenn
ell peuvent pas être en demiteinte ben
non mais au début quand tu testes tu es
pas à l'aise donc tu la vends un peu
genre j'ai un peu honte et euh mais oui
oui mais sinon c'est très agréable de le
faire par contre tuas vraiment choisi le
pire standup tous les sujets
sensibles c'est vrai dans ton spectacle
s'appelle hier j'arrê et et du coup il
parle de la drogue de la maladie
d'autres sujets de toi beaucoup beaucoup
de sujets dans mon spectacle je parle
vite en plus donc je pense que peut-être
il y a deux spectacles dans ça tu le
joues où hier j'arrête là tu es en tourn
en ce moment ouais tourné en ce moment
au Trianon mais là le 1er novembre c'est
complet mais le prochain Trianon c'est
le 23 février je crois 23 février au
Trianon et on tournait partout ouais
sinon on tournait partout bon ben merci
ben merci à toiir t'allonger ah ouais
c'est incroyable j'aurais pu l'écouter
parler encore plus longtemps et je pense
que vous aussi et dans ce cas-là sachez
que l'épisode va être disponible en
version podcast et en version longue je
vous mets les liens dans la description
pour tout ça description qui contient
aussi tous les anciens épisodes de
l'interview à la table m'appelle
toujours Fabi licar à très bientôt Ciao